my mom
[Music]
ah
[Music]
yeah
president from famously called for hope
to all Muslim integration during the
campaign total and complete shutdown of
Muslims entering the United States until
our country's representatives can figure
out what the hell is going on
he seems set to follow through only a
week after being sworn in by signing an
executive order that not only stops all
refugees from entering the country for
at least 120 days and Syrian refugees
indefinitely but also puts a 90-day hold
on travel visa and even green card
holders from several predominantly
Muslim country this last one left many
travelers who live in work or have
family in the u.s. stranded at airports
and in many cases sent back home at Los
Angeles Airport for instance we spoke
with this Iraqi born journalist and US
citizen whose father was prevented from
entering the country
my dad was visiting from Iraq to come
see us see his grandchildren he's a 69
year old retired civil engineer he was
placed in a room with 30 other
passengers and he was there for about 12
hours
he didn't have his passport they took
his password
and then they put him in a plane and he
is back in Gaza hours after Trump signed
the order a New York federal judge
issued today saying immigrants suck at
American airports should not be sent
home the chaos ensuing from Trump's
executive actions led to protests at JFK
Airport in New York and in front of the
Tom Bradley International Terminal in LA
where reason TV was on the scene to talk
with demonstrators we do not close
America off America is open America
welcomes we are not going to turn our
backs to refugees especially when their
women and children
IBM Italy to oppose holding people the
way they are being held right now in the
airport for the reasons of their
religion this is not about political
ideology and morality I don't see how
someone like my god is s lam taking
specific country
you know haven't had any incidents no
Iraqi citizens carried any terroristic
house not to my knowledge
so are you that the president has the
power to just do this on its own without
consulting Congress at all you're asking
me if you could have the power to make
an executive order and I believe that
the good power for the president the
house I believe be poorly used it in
this instance and Obama issued a number
of executive orders including on
immigration do you worry that he is in a
sense given Trump too much power with
what he created in the presidency no I
mean the thing that with President Obama
he tried working with Congress he tried
and tried and tried and Congress which
does not work with him I'm really
saddened by the results of the election
and all the people that didn't vote for
the people who head third party process
and he's a site selection team so your
goal is sexually impeachment I think he
needs to go
you know you're with refuse fascism and
your you pets a lot a lot of these signs
and I've seen a lot of them around here
you think that calling Donald Trump of
fascist an effective tactic to persuade
people who are maybe on the fence about
him well it's not really a matter of
tactics as a matter of reality like this
is why he is and fascism is when they
strip away the democratic rights that
people thought they had such as due
process what what evidence do they have
to detain any of the Muslim people given
the past President Bush and Obama
included has detained Muslims without
due process and killed them without
declarations of war would you describe
those as special no it's totally it's a
different way of organizing society
where your swatching defense if you
could speak directly to its trump coder
who is supportive of these action
worried about what happens if we let in
too many refugees what would you say for
that person I'd say you need to check
your empathy look outside your little
bubble of who you are and your little
demographic and think about what it
might mean really truly be like somebody
fleeing for their lives
the refugee process to get here is the
most strict vetting process there is and
so you can't get tighter than how it
already is do you think this is going to
make America safer I don't know how this
will make you pay for actually I I
really really really am worried about
your citizens outside the United States
it will actually put them in a bad
situation
[Music]